white sandy beaches and clear turquoise
Waters this is the Maldives the world
knows and loves but the island of venil
is a small Oasis next to the Capital One
of the most densely populated cities in
the world just off the coast a new
project to try and remedy that pillars
sunk into the sea for a highway leading
to what's now just a sandbar but will be
a new cargo port and residential blocks
locals have watched as their idilic few
has turned into a building site they
take the sand using a dredger and they
put all the sand inside and this is one
of the biggest
reclamations doing in the moldiv and
that had a very immediate impact and
when we came out to have a look there
were sediment plumes like a cloud of
sediment coming and hitting our Reef
like it was this bad when they started
it now the surface waters are clear
again but the real damage is below
the divers here say the dredging has
already had a devastating impact on the
underwater environment the reefs in this
area have lost 70% of their Coral
coverage 50 m down the nearby reef is
still home to some fish but the water's
Cloudy and the reef covered in sand
corals look colorless with few signs of
New Growth hardly bustling with life
this say the UN is at the heart of the
problem treading s beds kills
microorganisms vital to sustaining
Marine
environments it's a tricky balancing act
for the government of a country that's
99%
underwater and vulnerable to rising sea
levels we have been even looking into
things such as relocation of corals to
other areas and ensuring that we take
the maximum mitigation protection
measures while we do Reclamation because
Reclamation is a sustainable development
need we have to do it but we want to do
it in a way that has minimal
impacts the residents of villing Gilly
are already taking action to protect the
reef corals cut back to promote growth
attached to frames and replanted off the
coast it's far from ideal but the only
thing they can do to protect their
environment from being Swept Away in the
race to expand Tony Chang Al jazer
villan Gilly the
MDES make sure to subscribe to our
Channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer